that governs the military title 50 is
the one that covers espionage and
intelligence activities um and sometimes
they'll be title 50 missions but one of
the things that the that the JSOC and
and the Pentagon sort of learned or
decided if you like in the post 9/11 era
was that they they had much greater room
to maneuver inside of the legal
authorities then maybe previous
administrations had had decided so you
know they took a look at the laws and I
mean this gets very complicated and I
couldn't pretend to be an expert on all
this and said well you know inside of
this Authority we can actually do this
we can actually put people under cover
we can actually do this we don't need to
ask the CIA's permission to do this
maybe we just need to inform the CIA
that we're doing it and their overseers
in Congress basically went along with it
they would have been able to do it
otherwise yes one when one has to assume
that that's that's the case right so
would you expect the black squadron to
to be able to to be I don't want to say
be known to go into other places but to
go into other places in an increasing
number in the future I think you'd well
yes I mean I don't know about an
increasing number I mean they're doing
they're doing it now um you know and
that can be anything from say living in
a safe house in northern Somalia to
putting an individual under a commercial
cover so pretending to be a businessman
or scientist or something in in Yemen
fight against Isis are you do you assume
that there are components I know there
are I can describe yes there there's a
task force operating out of Iraqi
Kurdistan um its mission is largely
targeting Islamic state leaders i it
uses I presume all sources of
intelligence to do that so from running
spies into the Islamic state
interviewing people
come out of the year's Islamic state
territory signals intelligence imagery
intelligence and in then it has its own
fleet of drones as well with which to to
conduct not only that that surveillance
of of targets but also killing them so
when you hear that a senior Islamic
state leader has been killed in a drone
strike there's a strong possibility that
that was a JSOC mission and what about
Syria well I think that certainly going
into into that's that's happening in
Syria I mean that they're there in Iraqi
Kurdistan but they're running missions
into Syria I talk in the book about
through the height of the Iraq war some
I think some of the most dramatic
missions that that small JSOC elements
to include single individuals ran was
undercover missions into Syria to to
keep tabs on the foreign fighter flow
that was going through Syria into Iraq
beefing up the al Qaeda in Iraq
organization any indication that they
they're now operating in Europe as well
as those foreign fighters flow back and
forth from parts of Europe I I haven't
been being told that of course that you
know the I've finished writing the book
about a year ago so a lot of what's
happening now in in in in Europe is
beyond the scope of the book but I think
that it would be difficult to imagine
that at least in the embassies JSOC
didn't have some some people working
with the intelligence folks there and
with their counterparts in in European
security forces do you you see JSOC
slowing its growth or do you or do you
think this is the force that we will
continue to use as much as we have to do
discreet targeted operations I think I
don't see JSOC being cut down
sighs anytime soon partly just because
it in the US government it's much easier
to grow organizations and to make them
smaller but also because successive
administrations now have come to rely on
Joint Special Operations Command for for
things that are too difficult in their
mind or too sensitive for other
organizations to to do I think that
you're going to see a change
perhaps in how JSOC weights its
resources and its efforts as I mentioned
already the the the intelligence
squadrons of the the the reconnaissance
squadrons are becoming more more
important in some ways than the assault
squadrons one bigger and more highly
resourced I am I think that you're going
to see more cyber warfare conducted by
JSOC entities and perhaps in different
geographic locations clearly if if US
forces are have now pulled out of of
Iraq not counting sort of that the two
or three thousand that are training the
Iraqi military and and and the JSOC task
force in in in in Iraqi Kurdistan then
you've got and you've you've got a
shrinking presence in in Afghanistan
although mm-hmm the questions still open
as to whether that's going to completely
disappear um you're not going to have
the size of task forces that were in
those countries at the height of the
wars there and the height of the
American presence there but that that
will probably lead to a JSOC being able
to get a little rest but you might see
just a more diffuse presence around the
world as well so one final question and
what did you learn other than other than
the stories of its effectiveness and its
evolution did you learn any political
lessons from from
what you discovered I think the small
pea yeah III think I didn't really
approach the book looking for paying for
political lessons I think the the you
know there are certainly lessons to be
learned organizationally in how JSOC a
reorganized itself mm-hmm I've largely
under under Stan McChrystal and and and
then continued by by bill McRaven from
an organizer I mean a large part of the
book really is telling the story of how
it went from an organization that was
fairly small and and designed for
episodic operations and and and then big
you know became an organization had to
turn itself into an organization that
was capable of year long
you know multi-year long campaigns 24/7
in in multiple parts of the world
simultaneously so there's there are
certainly organizational lessons there
how it how it engaged with the US
government and and our another set of
sort of lessons learned and I think
going back to what I said earlier from
the policymakers point of view the
lesson is you it's very important for a
country like the United States that has
the interests of the United States has
to have an organization like JSOC that
can do what it can do and we should be
very grateful that we have that however
it's a probably a mistake to rely on
that organization to do everything for
you absent more coherent strategy to
solve your problems okay thank you Shawn
Naylor thank you thank you
you
that was afterwards book TVs signature
program in which authors of the latest
non-fiction books are interviewed watch
past afterwards programs online at book
TV org
nutrition and food expert marion Nestle
examines how the soft drink industry
markets its products to vulnerable
populations in her book soda politics
good afternoon my name is Marvin Taylor
I'm the director of the fales library
it's a pleasure for me to welcome you
this afternoon
to a book party for soda politics taking
on big soda and winning by marion Nestle
I was looking back over my notes today
about when we founded the marion Nestle
food studies collection and I realized
it was fourteen years ago the Marion
came to my office and said I know about
this collection of books but nobody's
been listening to me when I tell them
that we need cookbooks in the collection
and then somebody told me to come and
see Marvin and so here I am and I said
well let's go take a look let's see I
reminded my Dean at that time that when
mr. fales gave his collection of fiction
or tried to give it to Harvard that
Harvard turned it down because they
wanted they weren't going to put fiction
in the rare book room and he gave it to
NYU and of course it was the beginnings
of the fails library and I reminded her
that we could be doing the same thing
with food if we really took food
seriously and so we stand here today
surrounded by 60,000 cookbooks and
Counting the largest collection of
cookbooks in the country and its really
due to Marion's work and to radicalizing
all of us also to understand that food
is more than just what things taste like
that it's how they're grown is how
they're sustained
it's how humane we are in the raising of
animals and that we can change
industrial agriculture I'd like to think
that it's only been around about 80
years anyway and in the ten thousand or
so years we've been cultivating things
it seems like a blip so I'm really happy
that she's taken on soda and it's
probably enough for me but it's a great
pleasure for me to introduce our third
partner in crime here at NYU Clark Wolfe
who has helped us create the critical
topics in food series another important
link in building the collections here
and doing programming like this so
please join me in welcoming Clark Wolfe
thank you
Thank You Marvin and I just want to
point out first of all that the fails
and the marion Nestle food studies
collection greatly welcomes the
enlightened eaters from the James Beard
Foundation let's give them all a large
round of applause we're so thrilled that
you're here you see that nice man in the
other camera there that's c-span and
this is going to be part of book TV as
is untraditional or non-traditional in
our 10 years of doing critical topics
panels today when we have a Q&A session
at the end actually you don't have to
write things on a 3 by 5 card we trust
Marion and she'll cut you off believe me
and I will have a microphone if you have
a question when you have a question
please wait until I get to you with the
microphone so that it can be recorded
not just for c-span but for the archives
these panels of all sorts some of them
Marion's books of which we are all very
proud and very pleased are kept for
students to use all over the world and
they in fact are next year will be the
20th anniversary of the Food Studies
department and program let's hear it for
that it's unbelievable and for that
Marion is also of course largely
responsible but next year our critical
topics in food series will include
probably four or five sessions and it'll
be food studies 20 years in nutrition
food studies 20 years in teaching and
studying and each panel will have alumni
will have currently teaching professors
and will have at least one forward
department chair or acting chair from
the last 20 years so it will be
fascinating the panelists will be chosen
or brought back from our family our
larger faculty of food studies pals from
all over the country but I will let
Chrisman introduce Marion officially but
I can't help it I have to read you
something from the foreword written by
Mark Bittman
do you remember him he used to write for
the New York Times one great thing about
Marion is that she's not a pure academic
she does not merely describe problems
although she does that with unerring
accuracy and wit to partially quote her
she does everything
possible to discourage the marketing
promotion and political protection of
sugary drinks to her soda is not just an
interesting marketing phenomenon it's a
concrete threat to our public health and
she is here not only to describe that
threat but to help us figure out how to
combat it
she's uniquely equipped to do so there
is not a better educated and I'm talking
not only about school learning but also
about daily reading writing and other
ongoing hard work and more principal
person in her field and that's mark who
is not excessive with his praise in
general but to do the official welcome
of Marian please welcome the director of
strategic development for the James
Beard Foundation Chris moon Thank You
Clark and good evening welcome to
enlightened eaters everyone it's really
a delight to have you here and to be
partnering here with NYU enlightened
eaters is an educational series that the
beard foundation began in 2012 that's
really focused on sustainability
nutrition health and environmental
issues we've been slowly ramping it up
over the years and are really thrilled
to have partnered with slow food New
York this year as well as a natural
gourmet Institute to bring this series
to a broader audience around New York
it's been really a thrill to see the way
that it has grown this year and looking
out at this audience is just one example
of that I want to quickly say a few
thank-yous to Jackie soman and the
natural gourmet Institute for their
partnership and the great snacks that
you're going to enjoy after Marion's
talk today Maggie she and Anthony facio
at slow food New York who have been
really key partners this year Marvin
Taylor and NYU fails library of course
for hosting us and Clark Wolfe and
Lauren Hill from Oxford University Press
for their support and tonight's event
all of this would not be possible
without all of you so thank you very
much
and now it's my pleasure to introduce
dr. marion Nestle dr. Nestle is the
Paulette Goddard professor in the
department of nutrition food studies in
public health here at New York
University she's been a great friend to
the James Beard Foundation was a
recipient of our Leadership Award in
2013 for her research and writing on how
science and society influenced dietary
advice and practice and the impact that
has had on our food system and improving
the way America eats her most recent
books were published in 2013 the 10th
anniversary edition of
politics why calories count and eat
drink vote and her latest book soda
politics taking on big soda and winning
which she's sharing with us today was
just published by Oxford University
Press last week so this is a real treat
to be here with you today so please join
me in giving a warm welcome to dr.
marion Nestle thank you Chris and thank
you everybody for coming this is really
exciting and it feels like a party a
birthday party for soda politics my
latest book and a several of you have
said how did you come to write this book
and your timing is perfect the New York
Times is writing all these articles
about sodas and how did you manage to do
that and my answer to that is I think
I've been scooped by the New York Times
yeah I'm not sure how I feel about that
but sodas are a big issue and three
years ago when my then agent Lydia wills
and another one of her clients Neal bear
came to me and said you know you really
ought to write a book about sodas I just
thought it was a completely brilliant
idea and I thought it was a brilliant
idea because I was teaching courses on
food policy in politics at NYU and I had
just finished planning a course on food
advocacy and I thought that sodas would
bring everything together in a way that
would make perfect sense I was pretty
sure there would be very rich material
involved in it and so I wrote this book
and I thought what I would do today
would be to read a very very short
section of it in the introduction and
then talk about what it was like to
write the book what I discovered from
writing it that really surprised me and
where I think this whole field is headed
and I'll try to do that pretty quickly
so I'll start by reading a little
section from the introduction just to
talk about what this book is about
health advocates to start by asking some
basic questions about soda how did
products containing absurdly inexpensive
ingredients sugar and water and not much
else
and the water comes from the tap for the
most part become multi-billion dollar
industries and international brand icons
how did products that are essentially
candy and liquid form come to be
considered acceptable for children as
well as adults to drink as a substitute
for water
what do soda companies do overtly and
covertly to discourage legislators and
health officials from focusing on their
products as targets of drink less
messages how did these companies promote
that brand loyalty so intense that
consumers of sodas will take to the
streets to defend their inalienable
right to consume as much soda as they
want and how does soft drink companies
use their own version of the science to
promote their products as essential for
well-being and happiness this book
addresses these questions from the
standpoint of advocacy when what those
of us who care about such issues
individually and collectively can do to
counter soda marketing and create a
healthier food environment for ourselves
and our children
I wrote soda politics to address such
questions why you may wonder is such a
book needed and why now doesn't everyone
know that sodas are bad for you this is
hardly the first book to take a critical
look at soda companies indeed as I
explained in one of the appendices to
this book an entire library can be
filled with books about coca-cola
pepsi-cola the soda industry its
marketing its executives the bad things
that it's doing in Latin America etc etc
but I view the soda situation in the
United States as having reached a
tipping point sodas are worth reading
about for two reasons health and
Vica see by now research overwhelmingly
linked soda consumption to overweight
poor health and type 2 diabetes and
demonstrates that these illnesses pose
critical problems not only for the
people who have them but also for
society as a whole the cost of obesity
alone is runs into the hundreds of
billions of dollars as for advocacy
sodas are in public health jargon
low-hanging fruit easy targets the
drinks contain sugars but nothing else
of any nutritional value and this
explains in part why sodas are so useful
as a target for successful advocacy soda
consumption is falling in the United
States and that is the overriding
message that I got from the research
soda sales are falling and advocacy has
a great deal to do with that we're not
buying Coke and Pepsi the way we used to
and we are only partially replacing the
products with sugary drinks this did not
happen accidentally as any soda company
executive will tell you health advocacy
is the single greatest threat to soda
company profits advocates with far fewer
resources than soda companies have used
their democratic rights as citizens and
time-honored methods for promoting
social change to counter soda industry
marketing lobbying in public relations
advocates are gaining increasing public
support and scoring wins with all signs
pointing to more to come I argue in this
book that declining soda sales are a
result of effective food advocacy and
that this example provides lessons
readily applicable to other advocacy
targets this book unlike other books
about the soda industry explains why
advocacy is so badly needed and how food
and health advocacy can best be used to
promote desirable social changes so in
other words I'm trying to foment a
revolution with this book and to be
Angie
use it as a way as a manual for how to
affect social change for food system
issues to promote health and to promote
environmental sustainability in the food
system so I had a lot of fun writing it
there was an extraordinary amount of
literature available plowing through the
number of books that had been written
about the solar industry actually turned
out to be kind of a pleasure as well
because so many of them are
extraordinarily outstanding works of
scholarship histories biographies of the
leaders of the companies books about
soda industry the soda industry's work
in Latin America and overseas it's
breaking up of unions I mean the most
amazing kinds of things and reading this
literature was it was really instructive
one of the things I didn't do when I was
researching the book was to go to
coca-cola world in Atlanta but I made up
for that lack last week and I want to
say just a few things about coca-cola
world in a way I wish that I had gone
there while I was writing the book and
as I wish that those New York Times
articles had come out while I was
writing the book because Coca Cola's
listing of all of the organizations that
it funds would have made my work much
much easier I had some of that
information but not all but I came away
from coca-cola world which starts out
where you're required to watch a film
about how many of you have been there
isn't it wonderful
yeah you pay $16 to be marketed to for
however long that you're in there and it
starts out with a movie that is so
touching and so emotionally so deeply
emotional that there is a single dry eye
in the house including mine and the
movie is showing moments of happiness in
people's lives and extraordinarily
touching a
then after you watch this and you're
kind of wiping your eyes because it's
really touching you go out and then see
how coca-cola has been marketed you go
to exhibits about the history of the
company and then you go up and taste all
the products and that was revelatory
because I tasted about I don't know
maybe 50 60 different products coca-cola
products from all over the world and I
could see immediately what the company's
problem is because coca-cola tastes
better than all of them
and so that's a big problem nowhere in
coca-cola world is there a word about
obesity type 2 diabetes or the very
strongly researched link between high
consumption of sugar-sweetened beverages
and those conditions you just don't see
it anywhere you also don't see anything
about the company's marketing to
children marketing to African Americans
and Hispanics marketing to low-income
people marketing overseas to developing
countries or any of the ways in which
these companies work behind the scene to
protect the environment for sales of
their products and this is what this the
book is about the book is about how the
soda industry markets to all of those
different groups the history of how it
happened how they're doing it now and in
many ways how advocacy is trying to
fight back about some of these things
and I ended up I described these
marketing techniques in the book in two
categories what I call softball
techniques and hardball techniques when
I came back from coca-cola world I
thought no I'm really dealing with an
industry that's schizophrenic
particularly the cola company which
greatly dominates the industry the Coca
Cola is a schizophrenic company on the
one hand it's happiness and love and
moments of deep emotional joy
accompanied by coca-cola
and on the other hand it's a company
that is what
behind the scenes to make sure that no
legislator proposes a regulation that's
going to restrict sales of soda that
nobody does soda taxes that nobody does
caps on soda something that we in New
York lived through and that there is
nothing that will stop the company from
selling its products over and over and
over again and I thought I think of the
company now as dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
there's the really nice dr. Jekyll who
really cares about people and wants
children to be happy and then there's
mr. Hyde who was trying to figure out
every possible way in which you can
spend millions of dollars to fight soda
taxes or to fight 16-ounce soda cap that
Mayor Bloomberg proposed in New York and
for those of us who lived through that
it was fascinating to watch the soda
industry in action Coca Cola it wasn't
directly involved but it funds the
American Beverage Association which is
the trade association for the soda
industry dominated by coca-cola PepsiCo
and to a lesser extent Dr Pepper Dr
Pepper Snapple but I saw what the
industry did first of all I got mailings
to my home so that were labeled American
Beverage Association so I knew they came
from there there were TV ads there were
planes flying overhead with banners
there were signs on the back of
coca-cola and Pepsi truck saying don't
let don't let the mayor tell you what to
drink there was an enormous lobbying
effort there were lawsuits which
interestingly enough the largest
african-american and Hispanic
organization supported maybe because the
soda industry had been funding those
organizations for many many years and
there were ads in the paper you the
famous ad in the New York Times of Mayor
Bloomberg in a blue dress
you don't want a nanny for a mayor and
fortunately Bloomberg has a sense of
humor so he when he was asked about that
ad he said oh no I would never wear a
dress like that
so unflattering but they played tough I
would love to know the amount of money
that the soda industry spent to defeat
what was to me a pretty trivial measure
I actually thought a 16-ounce soda cap
was too high they should have capped it
at eight ounces and you know nobody was
telling people that they couldn't buy 10
16 ounce sodas if they wanted to it
wasn't such a big deal but the soda
industry acted as if it were Armageddon
and behaved accordingly they've put
millions of dollars into fighting soda
tax initiatives in places where there
are elections where because their
elections they have to record the amount
of money that they're spending and so
they're you know that in Richmond
California one of the poorest cities in
Richmond they spent more than two
million dollars fighting a soda tax
initiative in Berkeley in San Francisco
which are Richard communities they spent
about 11 million dollars all together
that's a lot of money and you have to
sell a lot of Coca Cola or Pepsi Co to
fund those kinds of things you also have
to sell a lot of Coca Cola and Pepsi to
fund the salaries of the chief
executives of those companies which are
in the order of 15 to 20 million dollars
a year so these are corporations that
behave like every other corporation
using the playbook of the cigarette
companies very very similar to what the
cigarette companies did they're
following that play Beck look exactly
and while sodas aren't cigarettes and
nobody none of the nutritionists in this
room care about an occasional seven and
a half ounce soda it's the larger ones
that are a problem it's still a
corporate behavior that requires much
much more attention than I think it has
gotten in the past and that's a sense
why I wrote this book so my point in
writing it was advocacy because much of
the book deals with how advocates have
attempted and sometimes succeeded in
getting full sugar sodas out of schools
in causing soda companies to not market
to children under 12 on at least on
television and to put some restrictions
on how they market two young children in
other ways and I should say that young
children drink so much soda in this
country that the Department of
Agriculture is able to measure the
amount of soda consumed by children aged
2 to 5 and there are many instances of
parents putting sodas into baby bottles
I have this book is beautifully
illustrated and Oxford was very very
generous about letting me put pictures
in and it's got a picture of soda baby
bottles in it one thing that I learned
that I hadn't known before was only half
the population in the country drinks
sodas so the other half drinks lots more
and that the average consumption in the
United States is between 10 and 12
ounces a day per capita and that means
men women and little tiny babies and if
half the population doesn't drink any
the other half is drinking a lot more
than that and of course that's the
segment of the population that's most
at-risk for bad diets and the diseases
that go with it so the the end winning
part of the subtitle of the book comes
from the effectiveness of advocates in
getting sodas out of schools in bringing
attention to the issues so much
attention to the issues that the New
York Times has had over the past couple
of months pages literally pages of the
paper devoted to a discussion of how
coca-cola funded a researchers at
Colorado and other universities who are
part of an organization
devoted to arguing that you don't have
to worry about how much so do you drink
all you have to do was be a little bit
more active and me and I'm you know I'm
I met with the president of coca-cola
North America last week as part of the
fallout from that article in which the
president of coca-cola National
International said that he was assigning
the president of coca-cola North America
to go on a listening tour to meet with
advocates and other people who were
concerned about the public health
implications of soda consumption and try
to find out why everybody was so upset
about it and I was convinced at the end
of our discussion that he's genuinely
interested in public health he's the dr.
jeckyl part of the of the soda company
and I thought he was not very aware of
some of the other things that the
company was doing and I don't think he
was lying to me I think he lives in a
corporate bubble as many people in
corporations do so the soda industry is
going to have to change and there's no
question about that much of its
practices have been exposed by advocates
who talked to reporters and in other
ways are moving these issues forward and
of course I very much hope that my book
will add to that he was aware of the
book he hadn't read it but the two
people of the two people who came with
him one had read it and said very
politely
it was very well researched
this is so I think I will stop now and
sort of take questions and comments but
before I do that I want to say one thing
about the production of this book for
reasons that are complicated it was
especially difficult and there were many
many bumpy moments when it wasn't clear
that Oxford was a going to take the book
be be going to a be able to take the
book get through the legal vetting and
so forth and I want to thank in you know
I want to thank everybody who was here
today the James Beard Foundation the
National gourmet cooking school and I
think slow food had something to do with
this - Clark and Marvin who of course
been marvelous in all the work we've
done here
but I would particularly like to thank
my editor max since heimer and max would
you mind coming up here please nobody
deserves this more than Max you I think
you open it now I think you open it
right now you can read the card later
but you should open the book right now
you have to open the thing right now
max sort of held my hand through all of
this kept assuring me that the problems
that we were running into would be okay
that the book would come out all right
and it's a beautiful book and it did
come out all right and we're both very
proud of it
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now I will answer questions alright
so we need you to speak let us know who
you are so that we are identified speak
briefly and into the microphone my
colleague in public health nutrition
Marian I'm wondering if you could
comment on it's very complicated because
Coakley's roads for countries like in
Mexico and provides ambulances to
hospitals etc so I know there's health
advocacy on one side but even the
government is very tempted to do nothing
about the giant coke problem because
it's getting an infrastructure article
about the funding of these researchers
was Retd with such shocked by the public
who read those articles people had no
idea that coca-cola company acted in
that way that the company decided that
it would go public on its and it would
be transparent about the organization's
that it was funding and it published on
its website a list of the organization
that it funds and it's a staggering list
first of all the list goes on for pages
and pages and pages you scroll and
scroll and scroll down and you're only
on the DS and you still have the rest of
the alphabet to go and various analyses
have been done of those organizations
and a great number of them are health
organizations hospitals the American
Academy for the Academy for nutrition
and dietetics although that relationship
has now been severed as a result of all
of the fallout from this the American
Academy of Pediatrics the American
Academy of Family Practice I mean an
extraordinary number of organizations
then there are community organizations
largely devoted to either health
wellness or physical activity an
enormous number of minority
organizations African American Hispanic
Asian
and so forth every one of those
organizations is able to do the kind of
work it does because it's getting money
from coca-cola but at what price
and the price it seems to me is very
high and there are many examples which I
list in the book and discuss of
organizations that were about to do anti
soda campaigns or drink less soda
campaigns were given a gift and dropped
the idea so the Mexican government is in
an interesting position because it
passed a soda tax and in part the
advocacy groups that worked on that were
enormous ly skilled and in addition they
had money from Bloomberg philanthropies
and they used that money very very
wisely and an evaluation of that
campaign has just come out I just got it
yesterday from Johns Hopkins and it says
that soda sales are down and what you
don't know was whether they're down
because of secular trends or because of
the tax but what the soda companies did
immediately after the tax was passed was
to lower the price of sodas in rural
areas but sales are still down so maybe
the secular trend will spread to Mexico
which had the highest per capita
consumption in the world and the the
government which is concerned about
these things is going to have to pay for
the obesity and diabetes and all those
other kinds of things and they're their
healthcare systems not prepared for it
so that was what sold them on at that
and very good research and brilliantly
done advocacy alright we have a question
over here
professor I'd like to know your own
childhood history with soda and I'd also
like to know since the advocacy has been
effective against this food product what
would you like to see the next food
product be that would be attacked mmm
well this one was an easy one I mean
it's low-hanging fruit for a reason it
sugars in water and no and nothing else
everything else is more complicated you
know if you were gonna go after
McDonald's you can get nutritious food
in McDonald's a man
be the best food in the world but it has
vitamins it has minerals you can even
get salads there and it's a much more
complicated target I think in general
portion sizes what I would go after but
my own user I come from a very very poor
family that didn't have any money and so
there were no sodas when I was growing
up that would have been added the
question they did have the money to buy
them and nobody cares about an
occasional you know there were six and a
half ounces when I was a kid that was
just so not a problem it was a rare
treat you know maybe a few times a year
or on kids birthday parties or something
like that you might have them it really
wasn't until much later when the company
started promoting much larger sizes that
they became a problem so it was a much
later phenomenon so I missed it all
right it's only fair that we left susan
Ungaro president the James Beard
Foundation asked a question thank you
the books sounds so exciting I got
bought a copy and I can't wait to read
it but since I haven't read it I'm
wondering about all these flavored
waters I mean I think that so many
people adults parents are thinking if
I'm not going to buy soda I'm gonna buy
flavored waters and how do you feel
about that do you think it's a good
substitute do you think it's just
another way of getting sugar anyway what
depends on how much sugar they have if
they don't have any sugar there's no
problem at all really I mean it's the
sugar that's the issue and the amount of
sugar that's in sodas is staggering I
mean as a rule of thumb it's about a
teaspoon per ounce it's actually five
sixths of a teaspoon per ounce so that
if you've got a 12 ounce soda it's going
to have 10 teaspoons of sugar
that's packets that's packets of sugar
so you sit there with your 12 ounce cup
and you just pour 12 10 of these things
in there
it's a glucose tolerance test and people
have no concept of the amount of sugar
that's in there you can't taste it you
don't realize it's like that and
metabolisms just not set up to deal with
that amount of sugar coming in in a form
that's absorbed so rapidly I mean there
are even
studies that say that sugars are
absorbed from jellybeans more slowly
than they are from sodas so you're
better off eating candy than you are so
does nobody would let their kid well
nobody that I know would let their kid
eat candy all day long or just you know
many times a day you know candy is a
treat but sodas are treated as if
they're a substitute for water whereas
water ought to be so substitute for
water and kids should get used to
drinking water when they're thirsty I
mean I'm a purist Mary and I'm gonna ask
you one not very long ago a restaurant
industry magazine had a top ten enemies
list and you were right after Osama bin
Laden things worked out better for you
than if they did for him but so far so
far speak if you will a little bit about
the restaurant industry and how they
pour soda out of a gun at huge margins
and pay rent and all the rest of it and
what the response you expect that
there's to be well one of the then
there's some nobody knows who was behind
the Bloomberg is a nanny advertisement
in the New York Times it was it came
from the Center for Consumer Freedom
which is a public relations organization
in Washington that is very secretive
about who funds it but the leading
guesses it was the National Restaurant
Association which is very eager to have
sodas one of the things I talked about
in the in the book is a campaign that
the soda industry ran called cap the tap
that may still be going on because when
somebody wrote about it there were
websites on it and all of a sudden the
websites are gone and they were gone
very very quickly but this was a
campaign to try to sell soda to people
rather than water at restaurants and the
reason for that is sodas are very
profitable when they are not in bottles
or cans and are poured out of you know
one of those devices and as a rule of
thumb they cost about two cents an ounce
so if you buy 20 ounce soda it costs the
where
selling it to you 40 cents and you're
paying a lot more than 40 cents I have
tables in there about what sodas cost at
the at various movie theaters in New
York and it's kind of breathtaking the
profits on them are staggering
so of course restaurants are going to be
opposed to any discussion about drinking
less soda oh hi I'm Lori Schneider I'm
actually a visiting scholar in your
department I actually so we're talking
about all of these kind of positive and
responsible things that coca-cola is
doing from building infrastructure and
supporting all of these health-related
organizations and I guess I just can't
help but wonder if that's really cheaper
and easier than just changing their
business model in a way that benefits us
in the long run well I think they are
trying to change their business model
they're trying very hard sales are down
let me say it again they're not they're
not that only down they're down to where
they were more than 15 20 years ago
seriously down and we live in a
corporate environment in which the
buzzword is growth corporations have to
grow and so coca-cola made money last
year and it made money from selling the
small cans because they could charge
more for them so part of their business
model is to promote the little cans the
adorable ones with your name on it I
have one says Marian and I have one that
says love that I got it a wedding I
thought that was really cute and but
they can charge more for them they are
charging more for them they're putting
an enormous amount of money advertising
the small cans and if people will pay
more for the small for the smaller cans
they're really happy to sell them and
they made money last year doing that
they also are looking as hard as they
can for an artificial sweetener that
will taste good and not get people's
chemical antennae going right now sales
of diet sodas are down also although not
as much as the full sugar sodas
and so they're just desperately looking
for something that will be healthier you
know they're not opposed to public
health they just need to sell product a
lot of it and so the question is what
you're willing to buy and that also is
there so there's a you know it goes both
ways
and they are in business to sell product
they're not a social service agency and
to expect them to be a social service
agency doesn't really make sense on the
other hand they can't advertise
themselves as a wellness company and
expect to get away with it and that's
part of the problem too hi Mary so my
questions are what what is in your
perception is the ideal relationship of
the industry with positive change and so
they specifically they are saying that
they're going to be more transparent
that they want to help be part of the
discussion should they have a seat at
the table in terms of policy change and
what should that look like yeah it's a
really tough question to answer which is
why you asked it thank you very much the
you know I don't have to be at the table
with the soda industry I think the
minute I remember this is a dr. Jekyll
and Hyde company so are you at the table
with dr. Jekyll or are you at the table
with mr. Hyde I think you're at the
table with dr. Jekyll and you're only
going to get half the story and so when
in in speaking of them you want to
applaud I mean I'm in favor of small
portions have one that's great
and in favor of them promoting public
health initiatives but then they got to
turn off the doctor the mr. Hyde part
they have to stop funding anti public
health initiatives most of what I want
them to do begins with the word stop and
that's not a very attractive way to have
a conversation with a company that wants
you to congratulate them on all their
good they're doing and so it's very hard
when you're at the table with dr. Jekyll
to keep thinking about what's going on
be
the scenes and I'm thinking about what's
going on behind the scenes no we have
another question here and again please
stand up and tell us your name Lynn
Ripley I was wondering whether you would
in view what you just said in particular
with respect to wanting them to go in a
better direction whether you would
support perspective where you would go
after the stock we have used other that
kind of approach where when companies
divest
divested themselves stocks from
companies who didn't behave in a
socially responsible way yeah you're
speaking at a coca-cola campus
NYU was a coca-cola campus only Coca
Cola's products are sold here PepsiCo
has a deal with the City University of
New York where only PepsiCo products are
sold at the city of New York this is a
student activist kind of program that
has to come about and there has to be a
real push for that I think grassroots
bottom-up it's not something that I
think can come top-down obviously but
the you know those techniques sometimes
work the real question is where what you
want the companies to do and not do I
want them to stop marketing to children
at all in any way not just on children's
cartoon television I want them to stop
fighting public health initiatives and
you know organize a boycott that's a
difficult thing to do in the current
political situation I'm not sure the
student the student body here tried to
get involved with anti coca-cola
initiatives and didn't get free I mean
they got it off the campus for some
period of time and then it's back and
there's a group called killer coke that
I talked about in the book they're based
in Brooklyn and the guy who runs it is a
guy named Ray Rogers and he bought one
air of coca-cola and that gives him the
option to go to meetings where he causes
no end of whoa so that's a possibility
you know as buyers should buy one share
of coca-cola and use it and do that but
students if you're here you could think
about these things
no I don't think I'm allowed to press
that but no I
two things one the book is on sale by
the new york university bookstore right
there and marian will be happy to sign
them I will yes and also the reception
will be in the gallery down at the end
of the hall there and I think it's going
to be quite extraordinary Mary any last
words that you have to give us to March
4th yes bottle cap go out and advocate
it works
[Applause]
incoherent you were not
Oh
a signature feature of book TV is our
all-day coverage of book fairs and
festivals from across the country with
top nonfiction authors here's our
schedule beginning this weekend will be
in Massachusetts for the Boston Book
Festival in the middle of the month as
the Louisiana Book Festival in Baton
Rouge and at the end of November were
live for the 18th year in a row from
Florida for the Miami Book Fair
International and the National Book
Awards from New York City just some of
the fairs and festivals this fall on
c-span twos book TV
well I open the book with seen the
explosion of the castle Bravo
thermonuclear bomb in the Marshall
Islands this massive 15 Megaton
explosion four years before DARPA has
formed but I do that because I think
it's important to know the reason why
DARPA was formed and that was initially
to defend against this weapon in essence
which there is no defense against and
that brings us to the heart of the idea
of the military-industrial complex and
this idea that we must always be supreme
we must have these incredible weapons to
stay ahead of the enemy and yet at the
same time there's a knowledge built-in
that the enemy will eventually have that
same technology and so we must be on to
the next and that that is that
give-and-take that Eisenhower talks
about but specifically when Sputnik was
launched and that idea that whatever
lofted Sputnik that Soviet long-range
missile could carry a nuclear warhead in
its nose cone to the United States that
gave birth to DARPA and the idea was we
must never again be taken by
technological surprise and it is amazing
that in all the years since DARPA has
really always kept America in the pole
position kept us the strongest there has
never been an overtaking of American
science and technology in terms of
weaponry you can watch this and other
programs online at book tv.org many of
this year's presidential candidates have
written books to introduce themselves to
voters and to promote their views on
issues here's a look at some of the
candidates books in his newest book
reply all Jeb Bush catalogues his email
correspondence during his time as
Florida Governor presidential candidate
and neurosurgeon ben Carson argues that
a better understanding of the
Constitution is necessary to solve
America's most controversial issues in
his latest book a more perfect union and
former Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton looks back on her time serving
in the Obama administration in hard
choices in a time for truth Texas
senator Ted Cruz recounts his journey
from a Cuban
immigrants son to the US Senate Carly
Fiorina former CEO of hewlett-packard is
another declared candidate for president
and rising to the challenge she shares
lessons that she's learned from her
difficulties and triumphs South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham released an
e-book on his website in my story he
details his childhood and career in the
Air Force former Arkansas governor Mike
Huckabee gives his take on politics and
culture in God Guns grits and gravy and
in American will Louisiana Governor
Bobby Jindal uses 14 events from our
nation's past to explore his vision for
the future Ohio Governor John Kasich
calls for a return to what he sees as
traditional American values in stand for
something more presidential hopefuls
with books include Democratic candidate
and Harvard Law School professor
Lawrence Lessig in the USA is lesterland
he argues for campaign finance reform
George Pataki is also running for
president in 1998 the former New York
governor released Pataki where he looked
back on his path to the governorship and
Kentucky Senator Rand Paul calls for
smaller government and more
bipartisanship in his latest book taking
a stand another entrant into the 2016
presidential race is Florida Republican
Senator Marco Rubio in American Dreams
he outlines his plan to advance economic
opportunity independent Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders is a candidate for the
Democratic nomination for president in
his 1997 autobiography now titled
outsider in the White House was updated
to include his time in the Senate and
the launch of his presidential campaign
and in blue-collar conservatives
presidential candidate Rick Santorum
argues the Republican Party must focus
on the working class in order to retake
the White House
Donald Trump has written several
bestsellers in his newest book crippled
America he outlines his political
platform and finally Governor Chris
Christie and former governors Martin
O'Malley and Jim Gilmore have announced
their candidacies but have not
least books book TV has covered many of
these candidates you can watch them on
our website book TV org next up dr. ben
Carson a former neurosurgeon and current
Republican presidential candidate
recalls portions of his life and weighs
in on current social and political
issues
good afternoon and welcome my name is
John Hughes I'm an editor for Bloomberg
News first word
that's Bloomberg's breaking news desk
here in Washington